good afternoon everyone my name is
Atticus federa and I'm a propulsion
engineer here at SpaceX I'll be your
host for today's starlink Mission which
marks spacex's 21st launch of the year
and 220th overall mission to tape
retract on your screen is a live view of
our Falcon 9 rocket at space launch
complex 40 in Florida at T-minus 4
minutes and 45 seconds the range is
green and ready to support and weather
is also looking good
the teams are currently tracking no
issues with the vehicle or with the
spacecraft
now coming up shortly you should see
those clamp arms beginning to open up
just below the fairing halves they're
strongback lower has started
the strongback or te transporter erector
as it's sometimes referred to is that
trust structure you see supporting the
vehicle
you can see those clamp arms opening up
now
after they open up completely you will
see that strong back move away from the
rocket
the strong back is the structure we use
to support the vehicle in its horizontal
position in the hangar the strong back
also helps us roll the vehicle out to
the pad and raise it to its vertical
position
in addition to structural support the
strongback also provides fluid and power
connections through the umbilicals
as you can see there that strong back is
beginning to lean away from the vehicle
in preparation for liftoff
coming up next at about T minus three
minutes we should hear that stage one
has completed liquid oxygen loading
teams began loading propellant on the
vehicle at about T-minus 35 minutes
as you can imagine it takes quite a
while to load one million pounds of
liquid oxygen and rp1
loading these propellants quickly is
just one of the many ways that SpaceX
has optimized the process of launching
payloads into space
unlocked float is complete
and with that the Falcon 9 first stage
is fully loaded with rp1 and liquid
oxygen
we're just awaiting the completion of
liquid oxygen loading on the second
stage
should be closing out liquid oxygen
loading on the second stage in around 45
seconds at T minus two minutes
looks like quite a nice day down there
in Florida should be getting some good
views of the ascent and Landing phases
of our launch today
foreign
you can see the periodic venting of the
cold gas in the area just above the
tanks
when that gas contacts the moist Florida
Air the water in the air condenses
forming those cloud formations
these two lock float is complete there
we just heard that stage two has wrapped
up oxygen loading with that the Falcon 9
vehicle is fully loaded with one million
pounds of fuel and liquid oxygen
now this booster or first stage that you
see on your screen is flying for the
fourth time today having previously
supported crew 5.
GPS 3 space vehicle 6 and in marsat i6f2
after liftoff and Stage separation this
booster is scheduled to land on our
drone ship just read the instructions
which you can see on your screen now
coming up next we should hear a call out
over the Nets updating us that Falcon 9
is in startup this means that the
internal flight computers have taken
over control of the launch countdown
Falcon 9 is in startup good news there
the vehicle is in startup in a few
seconds we should hear our launch
director or LD give the final go for
launch
SpaceX launch director go for launch
and with that we are go to proceed with
our launch today so let's sit back and
watch as Falcon 9 takes our 56 starlink
satellites into space
a few minutes 30 seconds accounting
came out 15 seconds I'm counting
it's about five four three two one
vehicle is pitching downrange
page one potion at t plus 33 seconds
Falcon 9 has successfully lifted off
from space launch complex 40 in Cape
Canaveral Florida at 401 PM Eastern Time
next major Milestone coming up is Max Q
which is the point where the vehicle
experiences the greatest amount of
Eternal external stresses as it ascends
through the atmosphere
Falcon 9 is supersonic
[Music]
just ahead of Max Q we do Throttle Down
the m1d engines briefly to reduce the
loads on the vehicle
power plunger nominal
Max q and at this point we have throttle
those Merlin 1D engines back up to full
power to continue to boost our way into
orbit
now we're about one minute away from a
very exciting portion of our flight we
have a series of back-to-back events
those are Mikko or main engine cutoff
back engine chill has started stage
separation second engine start one and
then after that we have fairing
separation
mikko's when we shut down all nine of
those Merlin 1D engines on the first
stage stage separation is when we
physically separate the first and second
stages from each other and second engine
start one is when we light that single
Merlin vacuum engine on the second stage
and when we separate the fairings you
will get a good view of those 56
starlink satellites on our payload
vehicle is following a nominal
trajectory
got some great views here of the first
stage ascent
main engine cut off
stage separation confirmed
and mvac ignition
and as you just heard and saw over the
Nets we had successful main engine
cutoff stage separation and second
engine start one
coming up shortly we will be separating
those two fairing halves and there they
go you can see those starlink satellites
now exposed to the vacuum of space
we will be attempting to recover those
fairing halves today on our recovery
vessel Bob
of those fairing halves are supporting
today's mission for the seventh time
on the left side of your screen is a
view of the first stage with the second
stage and its Merlin vacuum engine
continuing to burn on the right
you'll notice in that stage one
Telemetry that we are actually still
coasting upwards
both vehicles are following nominal
trajectories
we will continue to gain a little bit of
altitude as we slow down on the first
stage before we reach the peak of the
first stage's trajectory
at this point the first stage will then
start to accelerate back down towards
the Earth to our drone ship that is
waiting in the Atlantic Ocean
the mbac engine attached to the second
stage is continuing its burn this should
last about another four and a half
minutes or so
you can see periodic puffs of gas coming
off of the first stage this is our
attitude control system
when we are positioning a signal Bermuda
when we are above the atmosphere there's
nothing to react against so we must use
high pressure gas to reorient the
vehicle
currently we are slowly flipping the
stage to point those m1d engines in the
direction we are traveling
and this is so that when we re-light the
engines ahead of Entry burn we will slow
the vehicle down
you can see the first Vehicles continue
to follow nominal trajectories the first
stage now continuing to accelerate down
towards Earth and we are decreasing the
first stage's altitude
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet constellation designed and
manufactured by SpaceX to provide
high-speed low latency internet to
people living all around the world as
well as remote and Rural locations
as I mentioned earlier today's starlink
Mission marks spacex's 220th Mission
overall and our 21st Mission just this
year
those 220 missions include all Falcon 9s
Falcon Heavies and Falcon ones
coming up next in the mission is entry
burn on the first stage
that's the first of two Burns that the
stage will go through prior to Landing
this burn helps reduce the vehicle's
velocity as it re-enters the thicker
parts of the Earth's atmosphere
should be starting up engine one five
and nine for that entry burn in around
10 seconds
State what FTS is saved
stage one entry burn startup
there's that call out for stage one
entry burn
as you can see we are now slowing down
the vehicle for atmospheric re-entry
this burn lasts around 20 seconds so we
should be wrapping up here shortly
entry burn shutdown
stage two FTS is saved there's that call
out for stage one entry burn shutdown
both vehicles continue to follow nominal
trajectories
looks like we did just briefly lose
stage one Telemetry this is pretty
common for this point in the flight
stage two continues to accelerate
towards low earth orbit
you can see just how fast we are
accelerating now we still need to reach
about 27 000 kilometers per hour in
order to reach orbital velocity
as you can see we did this regain signal
to stage one
and stage one has just passed through
transonic speeds
coming up in about 20 seconds will be
the beginning of stage one Landing burn
in preparation for a touchdown on our
drone ship just read the instructions
The Landing Baron utilizes the single E9
Merlin 1D engine
just starting to see that drone ship way
below the rocket there is entered
terminal guidance
stage one Landing burn
there's confirmation stage one Landing
burn has started in preparation for
touchdown
should be seeing those Landing legs
deploy soon Landing like deploy
Patron Landing confirmed there we go
this Falcon 9 first stage has now
successfully launched and landed for the
fourth time
coming up in just a few seconds is the
end of the second engine burn
and back shutdown
we did just shut down the second engine
waiting on confirmation of good orbit
nominal orbit insertion
and there it is with that today's
Landing marks are 182nd overall Landing
of an orbital class rocket can also
signal Cape that includes Falcon 9 and
Falcon heavy missions
the confirmation of successful second
engine cutoff and nominal orbital
insertion that will wrap up our coverage
for now
be sure to check back to our social
media for confirmation of starlink
deployment expected loss of signal for
me to thank you all so much for watching
and we will catch you on the next one